how are you Phil I'm doing great dad
punches back on your show it's been a
while yes it has yes it has um so what's
what's been going on you know he kind of
been in the news here lately the last
week or so yeah I've actually been
vacationing in Hawaii this last week
with family as you as you know Amanda
graduated and so we wanted one kind of
family trip before she heads off to
college here at the end of the summer
and and so we've we just had a great
little trip and it was fun to fun to
spend that time together do you play
golf on your vacation not usually no
usually I'll I'll try to get away as
much as I can
let's see we would play golf on our
vacation but do people try to get you to
play golf your kids want you to play
going for them no I started them at a
young age but they really haven't taken
to the game by a man to my oldest
daughter played three varsity sports in
high school but it was tennis basketball
lacrosse Oh golf really wasn't one of
them
so when we're on what was nice about it
for me Dan is that when we're on a
family trip the fact that a tee does not
play we end up having other mutual
activities that we enjoy doing together
so that when when I'm home
you know golf is a golf as my job and I
love it and I go play in practice but
when I go on vacation I am able to get
away from it and I try not to touch a
club who's the best athlete in the
family uh well I guess it it depends I
guess it depends but my oldest daughters
is pretty good but she she doesn't excel
it's a one sport she's just very good at
all of them and I would say that I I
guess I would say excel at a sport but
I'm not great at all of them what was
your second-best sport
did I lose you are you still there oh
yeah there I am okay they are what's
your what was your second best sport I
feel I feel fairly decent at snow skiing
I used to my dad was an incredible skier
growing up and we we spent a lot of time
skiing when I was a kid I he started me
when I was four so I felt very competent
on on skis
I loved baseball though I wasn't I was
okay but baseball we're talking to Phil
Mickelson how much would the US Open did
you want as much as I could I watched
almost every shot when I got went with
the graduation was done and we had all
that we had a few celebrations and in
parties and get-togethers and so forth
but I watched as much as I could I
really enjoyed it I loved I thought it
was incredible theater I thought that
Brooks kept - played some phenomenal
golf on Sunday the back nine was was fun
to watch the way pulled away it was an
exciting tournament and then and then he
just kind of took hold of it I thought
that was pretty impressive
do you watch him then but I imagine
yourself playing that you can't help but
do that right playing the course in your
mouth I mean it was looking at 50 yard
wide fairways and no rough around the
Greens was I kind of I was salivating
but 16 under par was was pretty
impressive and it was more fun I think
to watch than to try to compete with it
was it was fun for me after 25 years of
not really being able to watch major
championship golf to get a first-class
view of all the players and all the
shots and it was very impressive how
challenged the guys are some of the shot
that they hit I was I was very impressed
being able to watch from the outside
looking in rather than the other way how
emotional was graduation day it was
emotional it was emotional but more than
that it was one of those moments that
you just cherish and just to hear to be
there for my daughter when she was
speaking she gave a very eloquent speech
much more so than I could have ever done
and with a lot of deep meaning and I'm
just so proud of her and I was so proud
to to be there to be a part of it and to
share that moment together as a family
so more than emotion it was just a
feeling of I don't want to say
satisfaction but a pride I guess pride
watching watching my oldest child thrive
you you need a caddy now apparently did
how long did you and bones been talking
about this parting of ways I don't know
we've kind of sensed it we knew that we
were hoping that the US Open would be
our last tournament together because we
started in the US Open in 1992 25 years
ago but technically we started in the US
Open qualifying which took place in
Memphis 25 years ago so it was almost to
a day 25 years and we knew that final
round that it was our final round
together most likely and it was it was
an emotional day for us but we've we've
had 25 incredible years where we've
we've shared highs and lows on and off
the golf course the the Ryder Cup
Presidents Cup team events have been
incredible experiences for us to partake
in because they're so stressful and
emotional we've also had a number of
wins but we've also had another number
of difficult times at danwon when I went
through the most difficult time in my
life when Amy was going through her
battle with cancer the first person to
show up was bones and his wife Jen that
that really taught me a lot because what
I learned through that process is when
people are going through a tough time
you just show up you just need to be
there and it was bone - who demonstrated
that firsthand so we've had these
emotional experiences on and off the
course highs and lows and I'm so
thankful and appreciative that that I
was able to share those with him I can't
think of a better person to have done
that with and going forward as my
brother who manages John Rob is going to
carry the bag take over the bag for the
rest of the year
and I'm appreciative for John okaying
because obviously that is my brother
Jim's first priority Tim is one of the
people that I love like and respect the
most in this world and
I'm very appreciative and excited about
the opportunity to spend more time with
them because when he left to coach the
men's golf team at Arizona State five
and a half years ago I didn't get to see
him very much and it was it was I really
missed him and so now that he's been
managing John I've been able to see him
in a lot more tournaments and now that
he's going to be carrying the bag I get
to work with him daily and I'm really
really excited about that opportunity
why do we think there's something else
attached to this other than a parting of
ways and a mutual parting of ways with
you and bones I didn't know that you did
well I I guess you can't help but think
that yeah because there was nothing else
attached to this with hey you know this
is going to be the final tournament or
this could be the final tournament and
maybe you just kept it in-house it just
feels like that there was something else
attached to it and you know I didn't
know if it was health I didn't you know
there were sobriety things that came to
mind but it just feels like it was such
a great partnership and I remember
having bones on when Stevie Williams
said that nonsense about how many
tournaments he had won him and tiger and
he was saying we've won X number and
bones came on and and I said is there
going to be a day when Phil has to fire
you and he said yeah there probably will
be so I don't know I just I don't think
it was a firing it was just we both kind
of talked about it and there wasn't an
incident it was just I think we both
needed a change and there's really no
better way to say it
you know I we both were looking for
something different and I think that
he's going to have opportunities to to
be on the bag of some great great
players I think a lot of the top players
are going to want him on his bag because
of his experience his knowledge his
ability to think clearly under the gun
is a Ryder Cup and Presidents Cup
experiences knowing and being having
such a high golf IQ I think he's going
to be able to bring a lot to the table
for a number of players and that's I
think that's going to be exciting and
give them a new energy through to have
an opportunity like that and and for me
like I said to have time with my brother
is going to be exciting for me as well
yeah it might be a situation like fluff
when fluff went to Tiger after
you know caddy for a couple of veteran
golfers there might be a change of
scenery I did want to ask you about
speed celebration yesterday
I love seeing emotion when you wanted
Augusta with the emotion there I'm are
the are the golf purist going to be
upset about this Phil after you know
somebody going to write the column or
talk about that hey you know he threw
his club or they threw a rake or burger
still had a putt to be made they're like
what is what is the proper decorum in a
situation like that in your opinion I
think the proper decorum is what
happened you want to show emotion like
that and they're there their jump and
their leap and chest bump together I
certainly am envious of that because
they pulled it off like they had been
practicing and it may be they have he's
won so much but I think that I loved the
celebration I think we all did but what
was really impressive and inspiring to
me Dan was that he did not have his best
stuff the final round certainly that
back nine he wasn't hitting it the way
normally does he was a cutting the
cutting the way he normally does but he
found a way to win and that's the that's
what's so impressive in fact you even
knew it as it looked like he was making
mistakes you even knew that he was going
to find some way to kind of pull it out
and and he did I mean and he did in
spectacular fashion it's almost as
though you're looking to see what he
does to to pull it out and to find a way
to win and that's exactly what he did I
mean the great the better you are the
luckier you get and these shots were not
lucky shots or were you know he's just
hitting hit him hit them and practice
them so much that that he's pulling them
off under pressure it's just fun to
watch let me let you get in your plug
about the K mpg future leaders they're
the you and Amy are part of well KPMG
sponsors and partner with the PGA of
America to put on this tournament and as
part of the beneficiary that they're
there a new program called the Future
Leaders program which gets these young
girls from high school partnered with a
mentor in the business world introduces
them to the game of golf gives them
college scholarships and show and shows
how golf can really be a part of your
busy
success because as you know we spend
four or five hours together on the golf
course and if you're in business you're
learning about your partners your
clients on a personal level on a
business level how you can better
fulfill their needs and so golf can
really be a tool whether they become
professional golfers or whether they
enter the business world to help them
succeed in this mentorship program where
you are partnered with a mentor who is
successful already in the business world
gives them a pathway to Succeed in
Business and so education is something
Amy and I've always been fond of and
believe is the way to get out and wait
for a better life and and this this
program is helping many young girls do
that it's KPMG and part of the Women's
PGA Championship later today Phil will
be in Chicago great to catch up love to
talk sports not golf necessarily at some
point again Phil so thank you for
joining us Dan thanks for having me on
good talking to the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience